S eisenh Howard deported 1.3 million
illegals it it can theoretically be done
uh and as you have a
deteriorating condition in the country
in terms of crimes drugs uh Economic
Opportunity and so on uh I'm not sure
that the Democrats would be on the
popular side of this also I'm not sure
the constitutionality of Joe Biden
waving a wand and saying well you're a
US citizen I'm not sure he can do that
what about
Daka look I'm not a lawyer so I'm not
I'm not I don't it's legal but I mean
Obama executive order was what do what
does Daka stand for can you look it up
for um deferred action on child
childhood arrivals right and so This Is
How They inch
forward uh uh they say okay well you
know if you were here as a kid it's not
your fault so we're we're going to give
you a path to citizenship and there's a
lot of people who only know America they
don't know any other country and so then
what happens is people on the right
compromise